confocal microscopy is one type of  fluorescence microscopy whose working  principle is based on fluorescence here  one fluorophore is excited by a  particular wavelength and  from excited state to ground state when  it moves back it emits fluorescence  now confocal gives sharp and crisp  images compared to epifluorescence which  are blurry but how is it possible  confocal used two principles first of  all it use laser for illumination and  second it use a pinhole to cancel extra  light so the laser is focused into a  specific volume reducing the  non-specific illumination and the  pinhole get rid of the extra light and  this is how we get crisp images by  changing the pinhole diameter one can  improvise the resolution  now confocal microscopy utilizes a  principle called z-stacking  where it collect the image stack by  stack and then project it in a 3d manner  and this is how we get those beautiful  images  subscribe for more